[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public Senna vous le savez
la promesse est dans le titre de
l'émission de du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons et justement
c'est avec la guerre des drones que je
vous propose de commencer Moscou a été
visé hier c'est une nouvelle étape dans
ce conflit qui a envoyé ses avions sans
pilote qui les produits et les fourni au
belligérant comment les Russes
réagissent-ils à cette attaque réponse
dans une minute et puis pour notre
second débat des bas volontairement
décalés de l'actualité du jour cette
question faut-il généraliser la semaine
de quatre jours pour ce chef
d'entreprise c'est une évidence ces
salariés sont plus efficaces que du
positif on a moins de stress ils sont
très motivés ils sont plus efficaces
mais réellement je le ressens dans les
dans les dans les process dans tout le
process de mise en place des
comme chez les clients c'est vraiment
vraiment très positif mais certains
économistes pointent des risques de
fatigue mental de perte d'interaction
sociale de difficultés d'organisation
des entreprises bref la semaine de
quatre jours ne serait pas adapté à tous
les secteurs ont confronté les arguments
de nos experts dans 3/4 d'heure mais
d'abord cette attaque venue du ciel hier
à l'aube la capitale russe n'est plus
épargnée par la guerre Hugo Lemonnier
quelques dégâts matériels et deux
personnes légèrement blessées bilan de
la première attaque de drone dans un
quartier d'habitation en plein cœur de
Moscou et déjà l'inquiétude grandit dans
la population pour moi c'était
totalement inattendu je pensais que tout
ça était loin que ça ne nous concernait
pas et puis soudain c'est arrivé près de
chez nous les autorités disent que
Moscou est entourée d'un triple anneau
de défense aérienne alors pourquoi
n'a-t-il pas fonctionné pourquoi les
sirènes d'alerte n'ont pas raisonné
comment les drones ont-ils pu passer
d'où viennent-ils le ministre de la
Défense russe assure que l'ensemble des
appareils mobilisés dans l'attaque ont
été abattus l'attaque a été conduite par
huit drone ils ont tous été détruits 3
ont été neutralisés par voie
électronique ils ont perdu le contrôle
et ont dévier de leur cible cinq autres
ont été abattus dans la région de Moscou
par le système de missile et de canons
anti-aériens Pansier
mais l'occasion est trop belle pour le
chef de la milice Wagner evegaini
Prigogine qui multiplie les outrances
avec en ligne de mire le ministre de la
Défense espèce d'enfoiré puant qu'est-ce
que vous fabriquez vous êtes des
salopards arracher vos DH des bureaux
dans lesquels on vous a mis pour
protéger le pays vous avez fait que
dalles pour avancer bordel pourquoi vous
laissez ces drones arriver à Moscou
signe que la situation est grave
Vladimir Poutine lui-même est obligé de
sortir de son silence le système de
défense entière a fonctionné de manière
satisfaisante bien qu'il y ait encore
des progrès à faire l'Ukraine ni tout
implication dans cette attaque qui n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué voilà on
analyse les conséquences de cette
attaque avec le général Christophe
Gomart bonsoir bienvenue ancien chef du
renseignement militaire Mariana périr
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste franco-ukrainienne vos
collaborez à l'hebdomadaire national
ukrainien Ukraine ski thesden et aux
médias en ligne desk Russie Julien
Theron bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous vous êtes enseignant en conflit et
sécurité international à Sciences Po et
vous publiez ce livre Le Pacte des
autocrates chez Robert Lafont Mathieu
croissanto bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous c'est drôle qui ont visé Moscou
Christophe Goma en quoi est-ce que c'est
une étape importante en quoi c'est une
étape importante dans ce conflit alors
c'est ça n'est pas un tournant de mon
point de vue mais c'est un pas de plus
on a bien vu que le sol russe commence à
être attaquer on a beaucoup parlé de
Belgorod il y a eu effectivement deux ou
trois drones au-dessus du Kremlin là il
y a un salon de drone donc c'est pas
exactement combien mais enfin sans doute
plus d'une dizaine certains parlent de
de vins d'une vingtaine oui ça me paraît
intéressant de voir ça c'est à dire que
de mon point de vue de militaire quand
on veut affaiblir un adversaire on va
l'attaquer sur son sol c'est ce qu'a
fait d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a fait les
Américains vous savez préparer l'arbor
ils avaient armé des B-17 qu'ils avaient
embarqué sur les porte-avions la chose
inimaginable pour aller bombarder Tokyo
et montrer aux Japonais que ils étaient
capables de le faire aussi à l'époque
c'était faible mais ça ça oblige les
Japonais pardon à augmenter la Défense
de Tokyo donc à s'affaiblir sur le front
des champs de bataille directement donc
est-ce qu'il y a pas ça derrière ou
est-ce que c'est autre chose dans tous
les cas oui c'est un pas de plus dans
une escalade de la guerre entre les deux
pays alors vous l'avez dit il y avait
déjà eu une attaque visant le Kremlin
c'est pas la première fois que Moscou
est visé mais quand même Mariana périmé
les yeux qui si on doit parler des
cibles tiens
de quel cible de quel cible ont été
visés volontairement ou involontairement
d'ailleurs c'est très difficile de ce
soir puisque les drones ont été abattus
nous ne pouvons pas être sûr et certain
sur les cibles
nous il me semble que les médias rues
sont tracés possibles trajectoire vers
certains ministérius mais le fait est
que ces drones ont été abattus dans la
banlieue assez particulière de Moscou où
se trouve même la résidence de Vladimir
Poutine en lui-même enfin lui-même
également la la maison de sur le fameux
boucher de de série en charge des
opérations militaires à l'Ukraine c'est
un c'est un lotissement tout à fait un
ensemble de lotissements en fait tout à
fait particulier ou vit toutes les
toutes les limites politiques militaires
et économiques russes
mêlée dans l'entre eux entre les hommes
politiques les oligarques et les hommes
de la culture on va dire tu eux aussi
soutiennent la guerre donc on peut
imaginer que comme mon collègue de
plateau général vient de l'évoquer c'est
cette opération à une visée plus
symbolique elle vise un impact
psychologique plus qu'autre chose mais
là pour une fois nous voyons
éventuellement un dessin à frapper
jusqu'au cœur des élites pour leur dire
attention nous pouvons frapper même vos
familles c'est intéressant effectivement
j'ai interrompt on parlera des
hypothèses sur l'origine de ces drones
dans un instant on va vraiment consacré
du temps peut-être je vais vous entendre
sur la réponse officielle russe
intéressante de voir que Vladimir
Poutine effectivement s'est senti obligé
de de réagir rapidement est-ce qu'il y a
une volonté de minimiser l'événement il
y a presque plusieurs sons de cloche en
fait dans dans la journée oui quel que
soit effectivement l'origine le Kremlin
se saisit de cet événement pour
réaffirmer
cet élément de langage qui n'est plus
des nazis mais des terroristes les deux
sont largement croisés parfois dans la
même phrase de les terroristes nazine
nazi terroriste mais là on parle
vraiment de théorie avec des images à
l'appui comme on le voyait d'un immeuble
civil alors on ne sait même pas
d'ailleurs si le drone a foncé sur
l'immeuble civil ou alors si c'est un
débris qui s'est qui s'est effondré
dessus mais en tout cas
d'utiliser ces images quel qu'en soit
donc quel que soit l'origine de
l'attaque pour essayer de dresser donc
ce narratif qui est qui a changé qui
n'est plus la Russie toute puissante
mais qui est la Russie attaquée en son
sein qui porte à conséquence à la fois
pour la mobilisation de la population
pour la mobilisation des élites aussi
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a quand même eu
quelques oligarques qui ont eu quelques
problèmes de de balcons ou de suicide ou
d'escalier de depuis le début du conflit
donc ça peut permettre aussi de leur
indiquer qu'ils sont eux-mêmes en danger
qui faudrait mieux resserrer les les
rangs et puis bien sûr aussi du point de
vue militaire avec les critiques qui
sont faites à l'armée donc de tout de
manière générale quel que soit l'origine
d'attaque effectivement le Kremlin sans
saisi pour essayer de serrer les rangs
la sortie de Prigogine comme on va pas y
passer trop de temps mais parce qu'on
est toujours dans l'outrans mais il faut
quand même un peu l'analyser on est dans
la droite ligne de ce qui fait depuis
plusieurs mois
ou est-ce que c'est là aussi un cran
supplémentaire il faut bien comprendre
que le général prix le prix d'origine
pardon qui dirige les ministres Wagner
sauf hypothèse qu'elle fait partie de
service spéciaux
c'est de notoriété publique on n'est pas
à l'abri de cette petite peut-être
des renseignements militaires donc
peut-être que votre petite erreur a un
petit fondement
donc il est pas général il faudra aller
dans les fondements de l'histoire
militaire russe pour voir
comment dire l'aspect vraiment très
éloigné de certaines forces qui
pouvaient être à doublé par les tombes
bon alors comment vous analysez cette
sortie là alors
russe au peuple russe qui se demande
pourquoi
comprendre que l'implication militaire
de milice Wagner ce n'est qu'une
composante d'action de Prigogine à
l'Ukraine et dans le monde il faut
rappeler sans cesse que les mélisses
Wagner c'est plutôt un bras armé d'une
entreprise beaucoup plus globale que
l'envers il se trouve par ailleurs que
je fais récemment une enquête sur un
mini empire audiovisuel qui avait bâti
un proche de privogyne dans les
territoires de l'Ukraine occupé ce qui
met en fait en évidence le fait que
toutes ces toutes ces sorties autour des
backmoutes autour des munitions cette
mise en scène de l'importance de mélisse
Wagner ça fait partie un peu de de c'est
comme une pièce de théâtre si vous
voulez qu'on sert au public avant tout
russe mais que son implication son son
intégration dans le système des pouvoirs
et plein il est il est il fait
réellement partie des pouvoirs russes il
fait partie de ceux qui gèrent
l'occupation qui ne font pas que de
conquête militaires mais qui
préoccupations y compris politiquement
donc en effet c'est on peut interpréter
ces sorties de ce point de vue en tenant
en tête qu'il y avait une Prigogine
n'est pas en le solitaire n'est pas un
acteur isolé on entend bien ça alors
vous vous dites le les uns les autres
que il s'adresse aux Russes je vous
propose de réécouter un
témoignage une réaction qui était dans
le sujet d'ouverture de notre débat
parce que c'est effectivement
intéressant de voir ces riverains qui
réagissent à la télévision et qui disent
leur surprise
pour moi c'était totalement inattendu et
c'est une mauvaise surprise que cela
puisse nous arriver
je pensais que tout ça était loin que ça
nous concernait pas et puis soudain
c'est arrivé près de chez nous
un mot mariage
[Musique]
des Russes est-ce que ça peut avoir un
effet sur le moral des Russes il s'est
passé là et c'est même pour ça qu'ils
viennent ils prenogie dans son rôle de
un peu altéréo une sorte d'alternative
politique
mais téléguidée enfin contrôler par le
Kremlin évoque justement cet aspect là
parce que la propagande peut faire
semblant tant qu'elle veut que tout cela
c'est sans conséquence bien entendu que
ça commence et que ça commencera à
affecter le moral de du public bien
entendu alors on jouait qu'on parle de
l'origine de ces drones je me tourne
vers vous Julien Theron Moscou parle
d'une attaque terroriste ukrainienne
l'Ukraine Kiev dit on y est pour rien
bon on a plutôt tendance à croiser les
skis depuis le début de cette guerre
mais bon quand vous analysez ça est-ce
qu'on peut être sûr que c'est drone
viennent du crâne ou pas non pas du tout
ce qu'on a comme élément matériel ce qui
est substantiel sans être une preuve
absolue c'est que certains ne serait
drone seraient de fabrication
ukrainienne c'est un bon début quand
même a priori mais vous savez quand on
fait un travail de journaliste de
renseignements ou de recherche on va
plus profond on essaie de savoir par
exemple il y a où vous aurez remarqué
quand même que les Russes sont présents
en Ukraine au contact et qu'il est tout
à fait possible qu'ils aient eu la main
sur des drones Ukrainiens par exemple
les forces de prix d'origine des forces
régulières
on a vu aussi des forces russes
pro-ukrainiennes attaqué en Russie la
semaine dernière est-ce que certains ce
serait infiltrés y compris avec des
drones Ukrainiens pour aller frapper de
plus loin dans le territoire Moscou vous
voyez ce que je veux dire il y a
beaucoup d'hypothèses possibles il est
pas inimaginable bien sûr que ce soit
l'Ukraine elle-même qui est frappé soit
à partir de son territoire on en
discutait avec le général effectivement
sont des drones qui ne sont pas chargés
à plein de forces explosives ce qui leur
permet d'avoir une plus longue endurance
comment il est absolument donc c'est
aussi une possibilité il est aussi
possible que des forces spéciales
ukrainiennes soient allaient en
territoire russe pour frapper du
territoire russe donc il y a plusieurs
hypothèses possibles ce qui est très
important en revanche dans tous ces
scénarios y compris dans le fait que ce
soit c'est possiblement l'Ukraine c'est
de ne pas croire aveuglement les
communiquer officielles du Kremlin c'est
ça qui est important et le Kremlin nous
dit et j'ai vu certains de vos confrères
moins sérieux que vous
répétez directement ce que dit le
Kremlin c'est-à-dire c'est une attaque
des Ukrainiens sur Moscou et personne
n'en sait rien vous ne savez pas je ne
sais pas nous ne savons pas est-ce
pourquoi parce que il n'est pas possible
de faire un travail indépendant
d'enquête en Russie aujourd'hui voilà
c'est ça il y a pas moyen de
reconstituer la trajectoire de ces
drones alors je pense que si certains
services de renseignements doivent le
savoir il est vrai que ce sont des
drones enfin les deux silhouettes que
l'on voit dans le ciel parce qu'en fait
on voit des silhouettes ce sont des
drones 100% Ukrainiens certains
d'ailleurs acheté avec du crowdfunding
quand vous achetez de l'essence en
Ukraine vous avez la possibilité de
mettre quelques centimes en plus
au profit de l'armée des drones pour
effectivement j'allais dire nourrir en
tous les cas faire en sorte que les
Ukrainiens puissent avoir de plus en
plus de drones mais je rejoins Apple en
position de Julien internation c'est à
dire que on connaissais pas en fait d'où
sont partis c'est drôle maintenant les
drones en question ont une portée
d'environ 1000 km donc potentiellement
ils ont pu décoller de du territoire
ukrainien pour aller s'écraser sur le
sol russe donc en fait les le doute
persistent il y a un intérêt russe à
dire on est attaqué pour mobiliser la
population et en particulier mobilisée
une population moscovites qui n'est pas
forcément concernés par la guerre de
quartier effectivement dans lequel qui
réunit j'allais dire plutôt les élites
politiques russes et donc dire bah voilà
il faut mobiliser solidaire soit
solidaire d'accord ça ne détruit rien en
fait ou pas grand chose ça voilà côté
russe côté ukrainien ça permet de dire
effectivement ça soutient le moral des
troubles ukrainiennes en disant mais on
est capable d'aller taper la Russie donc
oui pour moi il y a il y a doute est-ce
qu'avec un peu de recul on en sait un
peu plus sur la précédente attaque de
drone
dont on ne savait pas si c'était une
mise en scène pas une mise en scène
maintenant c'est un blogueur
ukrainien qui annonce les attaques donc
est-ce que derrière l'armée ukrainienne
est au courant parce qu'en fait ce qui
est intéressant dans un drone il y a pas
que la porte du drone qui compte c'est
également la capacité de guider ce drone
c'est-à-dire il faut avoir une liaison
satellitaire qui a des capacités de
liaison satellite pas tout le monde même
si Elon Musk a mis des satellites
Starlink au profit des Ukrainiens qu'ils
ont pu utiliser en effet mais donc c'est
pas n'importe qui non plus qui a pu
lancer ses drones de manière inverse
s'il y a bien un domaine dans lequel les
forces armées russes sont efficaces
c'est la guerre électronique ils sont
très efficaces on le sait au point que
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les Ukrainiens veulent des fesses parce
que certains F- sont spécialisés dans
les attaques de radar ou alors certains
drones aussi donc
l'hypothèse en tout cas même si c'était
des Ukrainiens mais qui soit partie du
crâne qui traverse sur disons 700 km
enfin selon le parcours le territoire
russe pour aller sur Moscou qui en est
entre 8 ce que dit Vladimir Poutine et
une vingtaine sans se faire remarquer et
décembre avant d'atteindre Moscou on
regarde des capacités de gars
électronique russe me semble un peu un
peu étrange tout de même alors ça veut
pas dire qu'il patate qui les ont spoilé
le temps de mettre en place et peut-être
le temps de réaction qui qui est trop
long genre de choses mais bon voilà ça
pose des questions disons très très
prosaïques
je voudrais enfin premièrement je
remercie mon collègue d'évoquer que nous
savons très peu de choses
jusqu'au point
nous ça combien détrôner il y avait
exactement combien d'explosion combien
ont été abattu et combien ont été
descendus par les moyens de de la guerre
électronique parce qu'on peut aussi les
jamais et les faire atterrir
ça c'est peut-être l'un des aspects les
plus passionnants parce que on peut
imaginer l'hypothèse que l'Ukraine
aurait pu trouver un moyen d'imiter le
signe le signal des reconnaissances
de sorte à ce que ces drones ne soient
pas reconnu en traversant autant des
centaines de kilomètres ce qui serait
extrêmement inquiétant pour pour la
Russie
ça pourrait aussi être le fait que les
drones soient mis dans le ciel du
territoire russe et qu'il n'est pas à
traverser autant ce qui est encore plus
enquêtant parce que précisément nous ne
savons pas combien des drones il y avait
mais nous savons qu'ils étaient nombreux
et je pense que ça aussi quelque part
c'est un peu le renseignement et le sens
un peu principal de cette attaque c'est
de montrer que vous voyez c'est pas un
drone c'est pas de drone nous avons les
capacités d'en mettre au moins une un
groupe nous avons et parce que ça ça
nécessite autant de personnes enfin ça
ça nécessite une plus grande une plus
exigeante organisation et ça montre la
vulnée vulnaire habilité russe
croissante alors j'aurais qu'on parle
des conséquences quand même
diplomatiques même si on voilà on a été
encore une fois prudent sur l'origine de
ces drones qui savent Gomar parce que
bon dans l'hypothèse où ils sont tirés
par l'Ukraine voilà il y a pour les
alliés européens et américains de
l'Ukraine des difficultés aujourd'hui on
le voit bien dans les dans les réactions
officielles la seule réaction officielle
enfin que je connaisse c'est une
réaction américaine du porte-parole et
donc un niveau technique qui dit
qu'effectivement les États-Unis ne
soutiennent pas la des attaques sur le
sol russe et ça mais il ne condamne pas
non plus c'est vrai il ne soutiennent
pas mais derrière ils ne disent pas
d'ailleurs que ce sont les qui s'adresse
pas aux Ukrainiens en fait c'est ça
reste flou cette cette formule et les
autres ont pas réagi enfin à ma
connaissance et puis ça restera flou
plus ça arrangera tout le monde
finalement oui on peut le Kremlin
ce qui n'est pas exclure par ailleurs
aussi enfin comme combien d'hypothèse
mais alors là j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à
l'imaginer parce que c'est
pourquoi le Kremlin ferait ça je crois
que pour répondre à cette question on ne
peut pas parler de on ne peut pas pardon
ne pas parler de ce qui s'était passé au
regard du lancement de la deuxième
guerre de Tchétchénie c'est à dire une
attaque une vague d'attaque terroriste
d'inspiration djihadiste dans le
territoire de la fédération de Russie
d'origine a priori tchétchène et
nagastanaise disons avec des personnes
et des fonds qui venaient du Golfe
et alors que la Tchétchénie était en
situation ne sont pas d'indépendance
mais d'autonomie des facto et ce qui
avait permis à Poutine qui est
absolument inconnu à cette époque-là de
se mettre en scène en disant mais en
fait vous pensez que l'État russe était
fondé et on va arriver et en fait il y a
des questions très claires qui sont
posées sur l'implication du FSB
c'est-à-dire des sas de sécurité de
Vladimir Poutine dans ses attentats
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
avait pas d'attentat de djihadistes à ce
moment-là il y avait des camps
d'entraînement en l'occurrence donc il y
a eu des précédents mais qu'est-ce que
ça lui permettrait par nous interrompre
mais il y a encore beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder qu'est-ce que ça permettrait à
vladimo Poutine d'engager dans la dans
la foulée de ce qui s'est passé là à
Moscou un changement de narration en
fait à un moment pendant le conflit à
peu près au moment où ils ont placé
celui-ci laisse 300 lancer d'un camion
au dessus du de l'immeuble du ministère
de la Défense parce que vous souvenez de
ces images assez étonnantes surtout d'un
état aussi puissant que la Russie mais à
partir de ce moment-là on a expliqué en
fait la Russie extrêmement vulnérable
avant c'était un pays qui est
indestructible qui était tous les
instruments le T14 armata pour les temps
que les navires les missiles étaient
absolument une puissance option
considérable que personne ne pouvait
arrêter et puis d'un coup on a dit mais
en fait on est extrêmement vulnérable y
compris à Moscou et c'est à ce moment-là
que on est passé de Nadia terroriste en
fait ils peuvent taper à peu près
n'importe où et on a un changement de
narratif qui est extrêmement important
c'est aussi au moment où le Kremlin
essaie de reprendre la main
politiquement sur les opérations contre
Wagner un dernier mot là-dessus oui
juste un animaux alors en effet il y a
des précédents et enfin c'est assez bien
documenté c'est pas une terrible complot
mais ce qu'on sait aussi enfin par
ailleurs on peut émettre des hypothèses
lorsque ce qu'on sait par ailleurs c'est
historiquement
les différents clans au pouvoir les
surtout les clans armés sur tous les
clans de différents services sont
capables de délivrer des guerres enfin
en tous les cas des compétitions assez
musclées
dans le cadre des compétitions pour le
pouvoir donc ça ce n'est pas exclure non
plus nous ne pouvons rien de savoir ne
rien ne enfin nous avons pas assez
d'informations mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui aussi arrivé dans par le passé
et on peut imaginer qu'il peut y avoir
enclin on va dire le FSB qui voudrait
jouer la carte contre le jeu héro ou
contre l'armée ou contre même le Kremlin
pour montrer c'est une réalité et pour
mettre à mal les élites en place
actuellement on a essayé de balayer un
peu toutes les hypothèses dans ce débat
on l'a bien on l'a bien compris un
nouveau chapitre je voudrais qu'on
s'intéresse à au pays qui qui
construisent qui produisent qui
fournissent ces drôles je vous propose
un témoignage écouté le spécialiste des
questions de défense et de stratégie
militaire pire servant il était sur
France Inter ce matin il parle des
drones qu'utilisent l'Ukraine
ils ont effectivement de longues dates
achetées au Turcs des missiles des
pardons des drones armés de missiles qui
ont fait énormément de dégâts dans les
forces russes et ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que avant la guerre la Turquie et
l'Ukraine avaient signé un accord de
coopération pour créer des drones de
nouvelles génération grâce au
savoir-faire ukrainien en matière
aéronautique c'est pour ça que les
Ukrainiens sont très forts sur l'aérone
et donc ce que vous voyez en ce moment y
compris des drones qui sont allés
frapper drones ukrainien que sont les
frappés à 600 650 km sur des bases
aériennes à base d'Engels à la fin
d'année dernière c'est parce qu'ils ont
modernisé des vieux drones soviétiques
en les boostant gomard quand vous dites
des drones Ukrainiens c'est de ça dont
on parle des vieux drones soviétiques
qui ont été boostés ce sont des nouveaux
drones fournis par d'autres pays ceux-là
sont des drones construction maison
d'accord plutôt civil d'ailleurs qui
sont militarisés de fait
mais construit effectivement sur fond
propre j'allais dire sur le de cette
association
ce financement par ce filtre de trading
dont on parlait à l'instant et donc
c'est deux modèles un c'est le modèle
c'est des petites ailes à l'avant et des
grands ailes à l'arrière avec le Bever
je crois et l'autre s'appelle Luigi 22
qui va un peu moins loin que le Bever
mais c'est de la construction locale
comment local mais c'est vrai que ce que
disait pierre savant à l'instant sur
France Inter et tout à fait vrai
c'est-à-dire que les Ukrainiens ont
acquisition de drones et d'ailleurs au
départ ça surpris les Russes qui
n'imaginait pas cette capacité
ukrainienne à utiliser un aussi grand
nombre de drones turcs ou acheter à la
Turquie qui leur permet effectivement de
de questionner des dégâts assez
important dans l'armée russe je viens
interrompre ces panne neutre le le ou
les pays qui fournissent ces drones à
l'Ukraine surtout si ça si on commence à
avoir des des attaques qui visent Moscou
oui c'est pas neutre et puis le drone
aujourd'hui est rentré dans dans le
catalogue dans tous les domaines des
armées on le voit puisqu'ils ont
fabriqué des drones marins de la surface
pour aller frapper la flotte de la mer
Noire russe qu'il qui confirme quasiment
la flotte dans leur port donc je veux
dire c'est un impact n'ose plus sortir à
cause de ses droits
il y a des drones d'observation parfois
ils utilisent des drones du commerce
parfois les civils donnent du du rime du
renseignement d'un intérêt militaire au
à l'armée en disant en fait j'ai vu une
colonne de temps qui arrive pas là donc
il y en a une participation civile et en
fait si vous voulez les drones ont une
capacité aujourd'hui absolument
considérable de l'observation jusqu'à
jusqu'à la frappe alors vous allez me
dire peut-être pourquoi ils veulent des
F16 du coup parce que l'intérêt d'avoir
un avion par rapport à un drone
effectivement en engage le pilote
beaucoup plus cher et tout ça mais en
réalité
l'agent a quand même des capacités qui
sont largement supérieures et qui
permettent de une spécialisation aussi
un port d'armes différents donc c'est
plus complémentaire quantagonique en
réalité mais l'armée ukrainienne a
réussi non seulement à acquérir des
drones à en fabriquer y compris parfois
avec une inventivité assez
extraordinaire par exemple l'utilisation
de ce drone qui est un espèce de drone
en fait porter et qui porte des espèces
de vieilles munitions qui seraient
quasiment pas comme des obus de mortiers
par exemple qui sont quasiment pas
utilisables qui sont dessous quoi qui
sont souvent des soldats parce qu'il
serait trop dangereux de les manipuler
mais en fait il est fixe et puis il est
là sur des soldats et c'est hyper
efficace et en fait de cette manière là
il y a de l'organisme sur imprimante 3D
Alors je voudrais revenir sur sur cet
aspect un peu bricolage parce que au
début du conflit
Mariana Benes qui avait il y avait
effectivement des drones civils
qui appartenait à des Ukrainiens et puis
ils les ont voilà militarisé en quelque
sorte est-ce que ça c'était vraiment le
premier temps les premières semaines ou
est-ce que ça existe encore aujourd'hui
alors il faut dire que tout commence au
début du conflit mais justement au début
du conflit en 2014 quand l'armée
ukrainienne était extrêmement démunie
démunies de tout et j'avais des
doctrines militaires dans de pratique
dans dans toutes les armées du monde où
les drones commençaient à prendre de
leur place l'armée ukrainienne n'en
possédait très peu et d'ailleurs elle
avait aussi peu de munitions
relativement peu de munitions pour
l'artillerie donc il se posait vraiment
question de correction des tirs
d'artillerie et les Ukrainiens très très
rapidement vraiment en quelques semaines
on commençait à bidouiller les choses à
s'organiser juste pour essayer d'aider
leur armée pour corriger les tirs
d'artillerie en sachant que
contrairement à la Russie qui peut n'est
pas compter sur toi à l'époque ces
munitions pour l'artillerie les
Ukrainiens ne pouvait pas se le
permettre c'est là où commence c'est
cette saga véritablement on commence à
acheter des petits drones commerciaux
pour les utiliser pour la concession
ensuite
tout cela a fini par révolutionner parce
qu'elle est soldats au contact des
drones ils se sont rendus compte que
même les petits drones même les petits
drones commerciaux peuvent être utiles
même pour un petit renseignement pour
sortir de chez soi pour voir ce qui est
dans les environs et maintenant l'usage
comme vient de l'évoquer Julien l'usage
c'est vraiment toute une gamme on a
toutes sortes des drones on a les unités
de l'armée qui possède par exemple des
drones militaires des fabrications
ukrainiennes et qui sont standardisés
tout le monde est censé les avoir enfin
toutes les unités ensuite on a d'autres
drones des fabrication ukrainiennes
militaires mais qui ne sont pas
obligatoires qui sont un peu comment
plus et qui sont tachetés par le
crowfunding il y a des drones
commerciaux il y a des drones qui sont
donc en fait on a vraiment une sorte de
fusion du profusion de pratique et
finalement le succès il vient de là
c'est on laisse le champ libre à
l'innovation et parce que l'armée
ukrainienne elle est très opportuniste
dans ses approches
et juste pour rajouter à quel point
c'est devenu important quand les
Ukrainiens a commencé à faire du
crowdfunding pour acheter des drones il
fallait aussi former les pilotes parce
que même pour les dons de commerciaux il
fallait fort mais les pilotes au début
c'était des associations bénévoles qui
offrait cette formation aux militaires
ensuite c'est devenu une affaire d'état
il y a maintenant un programme qui
s'appelle l'armée des drones d'ailleurs
qui comprend également les drones
maritimes des surfaces et le programme
est maintenant
conjoint entre les autorités et les
associations de bénévoles pour la la
préparation des pilotes et si ma mémoire
est bonne il n'y a pas très longtemps le
ministre de la transformation numérique
avait rapporté qu'on a déjà dernièrement
formé 10000 opérateurs vous voyez donc
en réalité je pense que ce genre
d'attaque on va on va innover on va voir
d'autres choses le suivi des militaire
finalement ce sont étroitement
si on cherche donc les pays qui qui
produisent ou qui fournissent des drones
Matthieu on va pas vraiment trouver la
France parce que notre pays a pas mal de
retard en la matière oui mais c'est
l'histoire d'un fiasco hallucinant au
pays de la DGA de Dassault d'Airbus de
safran à saint-fiasco bien connu où se
mêlent en fait tous les mots dans notre
pays secret jusqu'à la caricature
absence de prosput de vision prospective
réticence face à l'innovation réflexe
corporatiste rivalité industrielle
lourdeur administratif bref un échec sur
toute la ligne qui nous vaut aujourd'hui
d'être largement distancé de l'expliquer
plusieurs raisons il y a un rapport de
la Cour des comptes qui s'est penché
là-dessus qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
en 2020 il y a une erreur de jugement
d'abord d'une certaine façon l'armée
française a louper le coche à la fin des
années 90 alors que les États-Unis
utilisent les drones ils ont commencé
d'utiliser notamment dans les Balkans
puis en Afghanistan et ben l'armée
française accuse un retard comme si elle
n'y croyait pas alors il faut dire qu'à
l'époque elle a moins d'argent on est
dans des moments de coupe budgétaire que
les budgets sont consacrés à d'autres
programmes qui sont très entendu je
pense au Rafale et puis il y a aussi une
partie des militaires qui est sceptique
sur l'usage de ces de ces nouveaux
appareils notamment du côté de l'armée
de l'air on voit dans le mauvais œil des
engins aériens automatiques qui
remettent en cause une certaine façon la
notion de pilote auquel ils sont très
attachés et du coup faudra attendre la
fin des années 2000 donc c'est déjà
quand même assez long pour que l'armée
française en face un enjeu d'avenir donc
ça c'est première raison du retard il y
en a une autre et oui parce que là
commence à partir de cette période là
une période de guéguerre interne assez
assez incroyable du côté des politiques
ou de l'administration ou des
industriels ou en tergiver sur savoir
s'il faut faire un drone made in France
un drone européen donc du coup prend du
retard dans l'armée dans l'armée
elle-même ou l'armée de terre et l'armée
de l'air sans poils pour savoir qui sera
responsable de ces drones donc assez
retard de jugement j'allais dire ça
ajoute des retards d'exécution prenez le
Patroller qui est le drone qui va être
développé mis en place par safran mais
on en parle dès 2015 il doit être livré
dès 2019 là les premiers exemplaires
commencent à être livré mais il ne sera
armé qu'en 2026 voyez l'échelle de temps
le drone européen on parle de 2029 2030
mais là encore avant d'en voir sur le
terrain faudra attendre du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait en attendant on a
acheté des drones américains
essentiellement pour les drones de
chasse les Reaper on en a acheté 12 à
des conditions et des coûts américains
je dis des conditions il pouvait être
utilisé que dans le succès il devait
être réparé par les Américains bref un
cauchemar absolu est-ce que ce retard
étant passe d’être comblé alors le
compte est loin d'y être question moyen
là pour le coup il y en a dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
puisqu'il y a 5 milliards d'euros qui
sont consacrés au drone alors à
condition qu'ils a bien là où il faut en
fait pour reprendre un rapport
sénatorial de 2021 la France est en
train de combler petit à petit son
retard capacitaire mais pour l'auteur du
rapport qui était le sénateur de du
Territoire de Belfort Cédric Perrin un
très bon spécial du sujet on n'est pas
pour autant tiré d'affaires pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'un décalage entre le
temps d'innovation et celui de la
commande publique en clair la
technologie ça va si vite contre le
moment où vous passez votre commande et
le moment où le enfin ou elle est
validée et celui où les livrer il peut
se passer 10 ans 20 ans et le risque
c'est que le matériel soit un peu
dépassé à l'arrivée autre souci relevé
par le sénateur P1
la faiblesse de notre équipement en mini
drone donc ça si on parle plutôt des des
petits drones qui peuvent aller frapper
en kamikaze derrière la ligne et demi on
a pas beaucoup alors on commence à
rattraper Notre-Dame on a passé on est
faible aussi sur les systèmes de défense
antidrone ou là pour le coup on a pas
grand chose on a quand même pu récemment
des drones au dessus des centrales
nucléaires vous souvenez ce qui pose
quand même quelques questions et puis du
côté des lourdeurs administratives alors
là rien ne semble réglé je vous donne un
seul exemple pour finir la France ne
dispose pas de zone d'essai de longues
distances pour tester ces drones
contrairement à l'Allemagne à l'Espagne
nous on le fait en Afrique de l'Ouest ça
coûte très cher et c'est sous le regard
de gens qui se trouvent évidemment très
intéressés par par ce qu'on y fait et un
projet de création d'une zone test près
de Cahors qui a été déposée par un
collectif industriel d'élus et d'ancien
militaire et ben ce projet il est
toujours sur les bureaux des ministères
et il n'a toujours pas été signé
Christopher Gomar je voyais
je vais prendre juste un exemple celui
du décalage entre parce que ça je trouve
c'est intéressant si on se projette
décalage entre l'innovation et la
commande publique est-ce que
effectivement ce qu'on achète
aujourd'hui il y a le risque que ce soit
périmé ou est-ce que ça se
retravaille pas au fur et à mesure entre
le mouvement le commandant et la
livraison je pose une question
volontairement un peu naïve c'est pour
ça que j'avais créé quand j'étais patron
des opérations spéciales le un salon
dédié justement aux Forces Spéciales il
s'appelle sophisme pour se pêcher
opération nous forceuse innovates
innovation network séminar l'idée était
effectivement d'accélérer ce temps de
façon à permettre effectivement aux
forces spéciales qui utilisait l'intérêt
matériaux léger et j'allais dire
facilement des passages ou en tous les
cas facilement qui innove de plus en
plus et ça permettait ça donc en fait
vous pouvez acheter directement sur
place et ça évite à certaines
entreprises de construire son fond sur
fond propre parce qu'elles n'ont pas
suffisamment de fonds pour effectivement
développer un centre de matériel donc
oui il y a il y a un sujet mais je crois
que la DG s'est mis sur ce hormis le
métier
l'orage sur le métier pardon et du coup
ça avance dans ce domaine là mais
effectivement la problématique des
drones en France est une vraie
problématique et il a fallu attendre
j'arrive Le Drian effectivement pour
hacker les drones américains que vous
l'avez souligné qui ont été très utile
effectivement au sel en particulier
puisque comme patron du corps j'avais
été voir mon homologue américain pour
dire mais disons Bill est-ce que tu
aurais pas un drone à me prêter parce
que ça serait très pratique
effectivement au Sahel quand on chassait
les groupes djihadistes et les
terroristes donc oui de fait et lui
m'avait dit à l'époque mais attends moi
je sais pas une opération sans être des
yeux au dessus de l'opération pour
suivre de près et de fait ça change le
cours de la guerre et ça change et on
voit bien les Ukrainiens avec les mini
drone les drones type Parrot donc
constructeur français quand même qui
vous mettez une grenade dessous il va au
dessus et largue au-dessus d'une
tranchée russe par exemple créant
évidemment des dégâts puisque le il
cible exactement juste donc oui c'est un
outil indispensable dans le monde
moderne dans lequel il y a plus
aujourd'hui de bataille son drone et la
guerre en Ukraine le montre bien Julien
terrain juste une chose ça n'est pas une
fatalité c'est lourdeur administratif
les Américains en Ukraine ont donné des
drones qui sont assez récents qui
s'appelle des switch blides qui sont de
ton extrêmement léger qui se déploie un
peu comme un mortier comme je disais
tout à l'heure avec en fait je vous
laisse une espèce de munition comme ça
avec quatre lames qui se déploient donc
là c'est la lame en anglais va essayer
des ailes ils vont pas loin ils font pas
beaucoup de dégâts en fait on regarde
l'impact on se demande même s'ils font
quoi que ce soit mais enfin c'est
suffisant pour mettre hors de combat un
camion pour le 300 et un blindé pour le
600 ça c'est un exemple quand même de
deux technologies c'est quasiment locost
quoi et low tech un autre exemple encore
plus
intéressants de quoi vous avez besoin
les Ukrainiens leur ont dit et ça
rejoint exactement ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que les forces spéciales
ont une applicabilité ils ont besoin de
de besoin très rapide pour pour leurs
opérations et là de la même manière les
Américains vous avez besoin de quoi
dites-le nous on va travailler là-dessus
et six mois après ils sont arrivés avec
un projet de drone un nouveau projet
drone de drone notamment il coopère
enfin on peut être rapide dans ce
domaine je reprends la main parce que je
voudrais qu'on termine sur les attaques
parce qu'il y a évidemment aussi on
parle de la guerre des drones et aussi
les attaques qui visent Kiev depuis
plusieurs jours je vous propose
d'entendre le maire de Kiev Vitali
clicho il est au pied d'un immeuble
d'habitation qui a été touché par des
fragments d'admissiles abattus par les
forces ukrainiennes c'était le missile
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
contre notre ville en deux jours avec
des drones kamikazes et des missiles de
nombreuses personnes ont été blessées
cette nuit dans cet immeuble qui abrite
170 logements 12 appartements ont été
endommagés et une personne est
malheureusement morte
opération spéciale et menée contre des
habitants pacifiques de notre ville il
n'y a pas d'autres mots pour décrire
cela que le terrorisme
[Musique]
sur ce plateau bonjour bonsoir Mathias
pour faire face à ces attaques à une
arme qui revient avec insistance dans
les demandes ukrainiennes c'est le dôme
de fervention israélienne de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit tout simplement du
système de défense aérienne et
antimissiles le plus abouti du monde il
est d'invention israélienne vous l'avez
dit ce dôme de fer qui est opérationnel
depuis 2011 alors comment ça marche je
vous propose d'entendre Raphaël gerus
ALMI ancien officier supérieur des
renseignements israéliens il nous
explique les trois avantages principaux
du dispositif il est d'abord un radar
tridimensionnel qui permet de détecter
rapidement des projectiles en vol même
de petites tailles et de moyenne et
courte portée il a un ordinateur avec
des algorithmes qui lui permettent
d'analyser la trajectoire du projet
est-il détecté très très rapidement et
de réagir le cas éc et à ce moment là
donc la possibilité d'avoir des missiles
qui sont lancés vers le projectile ces
missiles possèdent des capteurs électro
optiques qui permettent une immense
précision et donc en plein vote à grande
vitesse de détruire le projectile
menaçant voilà ce système l'Ukraine veut
en bénéficier oui il semblerait que les
États-Unis soient à présent disposés à
lui en fournir comme la fermer le
lieutenant général kerblaire de l'armée
américaine c'était au début du mois lors
d'une audition au Sénat américain
a suivi une nouvelle mise à jour de
l'équipement elle est prête à être
déployée l'armée dispose donc d'un dôme
de fer disponible pour déployer
ce qui bloque et bien il faut qu'Israël
donne son accord comme lors de la
décision de l'envoi des chars léopards
allemands souvenez-vous il avait fallu
attendre le feu vert de Berlin problème
ici les pouvoirs publics Israéliens ne
veulent pas froisser les Russes avec qui
pour simplifier les choses il travaille
en Syrie oui mais voilà ces derniers
temps la Russie c'est de nouveaux
rapprocher de l'Iran ennemi juré
d'Israël et cela pourrait changer la
donne comme l'explique David Kalfa
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès lors de sa
réélection il y a quelques mois le
premier ceranien a fait des déclarations
fracassantes dans le sens d'une
possibilité pour les changer de
stratégie vis-à-vis de la Russie et donc
de l'Ukraine en fournissant aux
Ukrainiens le Dôme de fer depuis il n'y
a plus déclaration de ce type mais en
tout cas la discussion a lieu qu'on voit
qu'il y a un changement de la posture
israélienne dans le conflit Rousseau
ukrainien c'est pas un changement à 180
degrés il y a une évolution de la
posture israélienne qui se rapproche
finalement des positions de l'Occident
et notamment des États-Unis parmi les
autres freins à l'opération le fait que
le territoire ukrainien est très vaste
et qu'il faudrait donc beaucoup de dons
de fer pour une protection optimale ou
encore la crainte que de la part des
Israéliens qu'un tel dispositif soit
capturé par les Russes qui
s'empresseraient donc de transférer la
technologie atterrant merci Mathias
Mariana Perret Venezia que ceux sans ce
dôme de fer comment fonctionne la
défense entière aérienne aujourd'hui par
exemple sur les attaques de ces derniers
jours il y a beaucoup de de drones
russes qui ont été détruits avec
d'ailleurs des débris qui qui tombent
dans différents quartiers de la ville
c'est ça alors il est important de
rappeler que la protection aérienne
c'est pas c'est pas une chose c'est
l'ensemble de dispositifs qui peuvent
être extrêmement variés par ailleurs
tout à l'heure on a parlé de de mesure
antidrone parce qu'il n'y a pas que les
zones c'est des mesures anti-drone
figurez-vous que ce qu'on est en train
de mettre en place un Ukraine et ça
aussi avec du crawfunding c'est des
remettre en marche les feux de recherche
par exemple qui pourrait faciliter la
qui pourrait permettre à repérer plus
facilement les droites par exemple dans
le ciel donc c'est vraiment un ensemble
de dispositifs les feux de recherche
c'est des choses qu'on a vu pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale vous voyez
c'est le faisceau lumineux
mais aux approches de ville avec dans
les campagnes pour pouvoir repérer plus
rapidement les drones parce que les
drones parfois ils peuvent se perdre ils
n'ont pas des trajectoires enfin ils ont
des trajectoires qui peuvent changer des
trajectoires plus précisément donc il y
a cela il y a des petits armes légères
donc on chasse les les les drones
surtout avec des petites armes
portatives et c'est je ne dirais pas que
c'est l'affaire de tout le monde mais je
vous racontais même une anecdote qui est
presque drôle quand j'étais à Ukraine il
y a une dizaine de jours une amie m'a
vantait enfin ça ça coiffeuse et après
elle dit mais c'est très sympa en plus
la nuit elle chasse les drones vous
voyez à côté de cela on a des
installations beaucoup plus sérieuses on
a surtout la pièce maîtresse de la
protection aérienne de la ville de kif
en tous les cas c'est la batterie
patriote et en effet je peux vous
assurer que ça c'est le meilleur ami de
tout habitant de Kiev allez une réponse
rapide à l'un à l'autre pour boucler ce
débat Julien est-ce qu'il y a selon vous
une probabilité forte que ce dôme de fer
d'en parler Mathias ares soit
effectivement livré aux Ukrainiens on
parle souvent de la guerre en Ukraine en
fait la guerre en Ukraine elle est aussi
en Russie même de manière non classique
mais dans les arcanes de la politique
russe elle est aussi au Belarus sur
l'implication ou non de l'armée sur ce
qui va s'y passer et on s'aperçoit en
fait qu'elle est aussi au Moyen-Orient
dans les rapports entre l'Iran et Israël
on est dans une situation d'un conflit
qui est localisé mais qui est très
externalisé sur les apports d'armes sur
la technologie et de ce point de vue là
en Syrie il se passe quelque chose de
très important la proximité de la Russie
et l'Iran se joue beaucoup en Syrie ils
ont toujours été très en compétition et
en fait la Russie en 2015 quand elle
intervenu militairement je sais quoi le
militairement a passé disons un accord
une entente avec Israël pour dire Israël
pourrait aller taper toutes les forces
iraniennes et pro-iraniennes
en Syrie à partir essence faire taper
par les systèmes russes donc si vous
voulez à partir du moment où ils vont
livrer ça aux Ukrainiens ils vont dire
qu'eventuellement les Russes vont taper
leur F35 et le R16 qui vont taper les
Iraniens en Syrie et ça pour eux c'est
existentiel donc on est dans une espèce
d'équilibre de force qui est complexe et
puis quand on voit ça générale Goma
c'est c'est moi la réflexion il faut
c'est peut-être une la palissade mais se
préparer à un conflit qui va durer c'est
à dire que quand l'Ukraine réclame ses
armes là c'est vraiment qu'elle se
prépare à encore de longues longs mois
de de guerre c'est ce que c'est ce que
dit très bien le général Millet l'actuel
chez un agent des armées américaines
avant avant de passer la main à son
successeur selon lui la guerre va
malheureusement durer encore longtemps
c'est-à-dire que d'un côté et lui
l'estima possible que la Russie gagne
mais il estime que ça sera très
difficile aux Ukrainiens de repousser
les Russes au delà aux frontières de 91
et donc de mon point de vue on voit
aujourd'hui qu'à certaines équilibre des
forces qui se jouent sur le terrain
d'ailleurs personne n'avance ou recule
j'allais dire où cette façon très très
limitée avec des pertes très importantes
donc de mon point de vue oui
malheureusement cette guerre va durer
encore un certain temps merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur
public